AND A KEY PORTION OF THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT, AND WHO CAN
CHALLENGE THE CONGRESSIONAL
MAPS, AND WHAT ARE YOU PICKING
UP?
>> A BIG WIN FOR BLACK VOTERS IN
THE STATE OF ALABAMA.
THE SUPREME COURT RULING IN A
5-4 RULING A MOMENT AGO THAT THE
STATE OF ALABAMA MUST REDRAW THE
CONGRESSIONAL MAPS.
THIS IS CASE WHERE THE BLACK
VOTER HAD CHALLENGED THE
CONGRESSIONAL MAPS IN PLACE IN
2022 SAYING THAT THEY HAD A
MAJORITY IN 1 OF 7 CONGRESSIONAL
MAPS DESPITE THEY MAKE UP 27% OF
THE STATE EE
'S POPULATION.
WITH CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS AND
KAVANAUGH SIDING WITH THE
LIBERALS AND FOUR OF THE OTHERS
CONSENTING AND SIDING WITH THE
DISTRICT COURT.
A YEAR AGO, THE DISTRICT COURT
SAID THAT THE CONGRESSIONAL MAPS
SHOULD BE REDRAWN.
AND IT WENT UP TO THE SUPREME
COURT, AND THEY SAID, NO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE REDRAWN BEFORE
THE CONGRESSIONAL ELECTIONS, AND
SO A BAD MAP WAS IN PLACE FOR
THE VOTERS NOT FEELING THEY HAVE
ENOUGH REPRESENTATION.
AND THE SUPREME COURT SAID THOSE
MAPS ARE WRONG, AND YOU HAVE TO
GO BACK TO REDRAW THOSE
CONGRESSIONAL MAPS, AND THIS IS
A BIG WIN FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
CHALLENGE THE VOTING MAP PS,
BECAUSE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS, THE SUPREME COURT HAS
GUTTED MANY SECTIONS OF THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT, AND DEPLETING
THE ABILITY OF SEVERAL GROUPS,
AND MANY GROUPS TO CHALLENGE THE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF AN
ELECTION, BUT IN A SURPRISE MOVE
FROM THIS COURT, THEY ARE
KEEPING, AN MAINTAINING THE
MINORITIES TO CHALLENGE VOTING
RULES IN SECTION 2 OF THAT ACT.
THERE ARE COURT WATCHERS HOLDING
THEIR ACT THINKING THAT THEY
WOULD EVISCERATE THE ACT, BUT
THEY ARE DOING THE OPPOSITE
HANDING A BIG WIN TO BLACK VOTER
AND TELLING STATE OF ALABAMA,
YOU NEED TO REDRAW YOUR MAPS TO
GIVE GREATER REPRESENTATION FOR
THE 27% OF BLACK VOTERS IN YOUR
STATE, KATE.
>> YES, YOU HIT IT RIGHT WHERE
COURT WATCHERS ARE SEEING AS
TREND THEY WOULD SEE OF THE
DIRECTION OF THE CONSERVATIVE
COURT GOING, AND WHAT THIS MEANS
WITH THE CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY
OF THE 5-4, AND WHO WROTE FOR
THE MAJORITY, DO YOU HAVE THAT?
>> CHIEF ROBERTS WROTE THE 5-4
OPINION, AND UPHOLDING SECTION
TWO, AND HE IS THE ONE ON THE
COURT WHO IS THE MOST CRITICAL
OF THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT, AND HE
HAS HELPED TO DISMANTLE IT, BUT
IN THIS CASE, HE IS SAYING THAT
THE DISTRICT COURT, AND THEY
WENT THROUGH THE FACT FINDING,
AND THEY FOUND THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE REDRAWN THESE MAPS, AND THE
SUPREME COURT AGREEING WITH IT,
AND NOT DISMANTLING OF SECTION
2, AND TELLING ALABAMA TO REDRAW
THEM.
THEY VIOLATE SECTION 2 WHICH
PROHIBITS ANY RULE THAT DENIES
THE RIGHT OF ANY MINORITY GROUP
TO VOTE.
WE KNOW THERE ARE MORE DECISIONS
COMING DOWN.
MEAN TILE, WE WILL GET BACK TO
THE COURT ADDS THEY ARE HANDING
DOWN THE DECISIONS.
JESS LAID IT UP QUICKLY AND NOT
SURPRISING TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND REALLY UPHOLDING POWER OF
SECTION 2, AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THIS?
>> IT IS A SURPRISING DECISION,
KATE, AND MONUMENTAL DECISION
THAT SAVES DAY FOR VOTING RIGHTS
ADVOCATES.
THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT,
HISTORICALLY, IT HAS TWO PIECES
OF IT TO GIVE IT TEETH, AND
FIRST IN THE PAST, SOMETHING
CALLED SECTION 5 THAT REQUIRES
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE COUNTRY GET
PRECLEARANCE OF DO SDWROSHGS GET
ENACT O
-- OF THE DOJ
RIGHTS TO ENACT IT WHICH IS
SECTION 2 OF THE VOTING ACT
WHICH PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION
BASED ON RACE, AND THE QUESTION
WAS AND THE EXPECTATION WAS WILL
THE SUPREME COURT WITH THE 6-3
MAJORITY USE THIS TO GET RID OF
SECTION 2 TO LEAVE THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT AN EMPTY SHELL, BUT
THE COURT HAS REAFFIRMED SECTION
2, AND SAYING, THIS IS PART OF
THE LAW, AND THE THING THAT IS
REALLY NOTABLE HERE THE
COALITION THAT PULLED TOGETHER.
BECAUSE YOU HAD THE THREE
LIBERAL JUSTICES JOINED BY CHIEF
JUSTICE ROBERTS AND JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH, AND THAT IS SORT OF
BI-PARTISAN CROSS IDEOLOGICAL
GROUP KEPT IT ON THE BOOKS.
>> SO, WHEN YOU SEE THIS
COALITION, AND I'M THAT HOW BAD
THAT MAP WAS AS IT WAS DRAWN IN
ALABAMA?
>> THAT COULD BE PART OF IT,
BECAUSE AS JESSICA SAID, THERE
ARE SEVEN DISTRICTS, AND THIS
MAP WOULD HAVE GIVEN
AFRICAN-AMERICANS A SUBSTANTIAL
ADVANTAGE IN MAYBE ONE DISTRICT.
BUT THESE ARE APPLYING LAW AND
NOT OUTCOME-BASED.
YOU KNOW THE SIX CONSERVATIVES
WILL COME DOWN WITH THE
CONSERVATIVE OUTCOMES, AND THE
THREE WITH LIBERALS, BUT IT IS
INSTEAD, A STRICT READING AND
STRIPPED OUT THE POLITICS, AND
CAME TO THIS DECISION.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THIS AS PERHAPS A
SHAPE OF FUTURE DECISION MAYBE
ON A RANGE OF SUBJECTS WITH THE
CHIEF JUSTICE AND JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH SERVING AS A MODERATE
SWING VOTE THAT COULD PUSH
DECISIONS ONE WAY OR ANOTHER,
AND THIS IS AN IMMEDIATE
PRACTICAL DECISION ON PRACTICAL
MAPS, AND LET'S GET DIANNE
GALLAGHER ON THE PHONE.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT
THIS AS WELL, AND THERE ARE
OTHER STATES AS WELL VERY MUCH
AT PLAY HERE.
>> THERE ARE, AND WE SHOULD
CONSIDER WHAT ELIE SAID, JOHN,
THAT THIS MAY NOT BE AN
INDICATOR FOR OTHER CASES,
BECAUSE THIS CAME AS SURPRISE TO
VOTING RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
THOSE FOCUS ON THE REDISTRICTING
AS WE HAVE SEEN THIS BREAK DOWN
HERE.
THERE ARE OF COURSE, THOSE
WATCHING ADDITIONAL CASES,
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO DEAL WITH
REDISTRICTING CASES WHEN IT
COMES TO VIOLATING THE VOTING
GERRYMANDER, AND LOOKING AT
CASES IN UTAH AND NORTH CAROLINA
AND A CASE WE ARE WAITING TO
HEAR FROM THIS U.S. SUPREME
COURT WITH THE "MOORE VERSUS
HARPER" WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT
MORE DIFFICULT DEALING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE STATE HEARING WHICH
KNOCKED IT DOWN AFTER THE BIG
COURT CHANGE,PED WE ARE WAITING
TO SEE IF THEY SAY THEY DON'T
HAVE TO RULE ON THAT GIVEN THE
CHANGES IN THE STATE COURT
LEVEL.
BUT IT IS UNUSUAL FOR THIS TO BE
HEARD FROM THE VOTING RIGHTS
ADVOCATES, BECAUSE IT CAME FOR A
SURPRISE FROM THEM TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS IN FACT
A VIOLATION OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT, AND ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF
ROBERTS AND HIS PAST MAJORITY
OPINIONS OF GUTTING THE VOTES
RIGHTS ACT IN 2013.
I AM SEEING THE TEXT THE
MESSAGES COMING IN WITH THOSE I
WORKED WITH ON THIS FOR YEARS
EVEN, AND THAT THEY ARE SHOCKED
TO FAILING TO DRAW THE SECOND
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT IN
ALABAMA WHERE BLACKS MAKE UP 27%
OF THE POPULATION, AND SAYING
THIS IS INTENTIONALLY BREAKING
THEM UP WHICH IS THE ARGUMENT
THAT LAWYERS HAVE BEEN MAKING,
AND SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING IN VOTING RIGHTS CASES
CONTINUING THROUGH THE BASICALLY
DILUTING STRENGTH OF THE BLACK
VOTERS, AND THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
FLORIDA, AND AS WELL DEALING
WITH MORE OF A STATE LEVEL OR
LEGISLATIVE LEVEL, AND THIS IS A
MAJOR AND UNEXPECTED WIN FOR
VOTING RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
IT IS PUTTING INTO PERSPECTIVE
THAT ORDER BACK, AGAIN, IN 2022
ALLOWING THEM TO USE THE MAP FOR
THE 2022 MIDTERMS, AND THIS MAP
WAS USED IN THE 2022 MIDTERMS,
AND JUSTICE KAVANAUGH OF COURSE
CHANGING SIDES FROM THAT INITIAL
5-4 RULING.
BUT THIS IS A VERY BIG DEAL, AND
IT COULD PERHAPS BE SEEN AS
ENCOURAGING FOR THE VOTING
RIGHTS ADVOCATES, AND AGAIN,
THERE IS CAUTION STILL AND SOME
TREPIDATION FOR FUTURE CASE, AND
PERHAPS THIS IS SO EGREGIOUS,
AND AGAIN, THEY DO LOOK BACK A
YEAR A